the market for ketamine I think is
rapidly expanding this is a seismic
shift in the way people with mood
disorders will be treated over the past
few years hundreds of clinics
specializing in ketamine treatment for
depression anxiety and PTSD have popped
up across the country and some investors
see potential pouring hundreds of
millions of dollars into
ketamine-related startups this I think
is the new generation of medicine we're
really changing the face of Psychiatry
so how big is the market for this
psychedelic treatment who are the
biggest players and could the spread of
this alternative therapy impact the
market for traditional antidepressants
foreign
ly synthesized in 1962 ketamine is a
powerful short-acting anesthetic the
drugs first widespread use was during
the Vietnam war where it was used to
treat injured soldiers in 1970 ketamine
became a popular general anesthetic
after the FDA approved it for children
and the elderly the DEA classifies
ketamine as a schedule 3 non-narcotic
which means that it has moderate to low
potential for physical and psychological
dependence
the antidepressant properties of
ketamine remained relatively unknown
until Yale University released a study
in 2000 and what the study showed is
that the effect was taken within a few
hours and it was going into full effect
within 24 to 72 hours after treatment
Dina burkevalleva's Venture fund Simon
Adventures has raised 25 million dollars
and invested 17 million dollars of that
into 14 psychedelic startups simed also
tracks data related to ketamine clinics
we're estimating the market for ketamine
clinics right now at a billion dollars
and in the next five years we see
potential for it to two to three acts
although ketamine was shown to be
effective in treating depression by 2000
it wasn't until 2019 when the number of
ketamine clinics began taking off we
estimate that in 2019 there were
approximately 15 to 20. ketamine clinics
that were providing mental health
treatment fast forward to 2022
there's over 400 clinics in 2019 the FDA
approved a compound related to ketamine
called s ketamine for treatment
resistant depression
today we Usher in a new breakthrough
therapy in major depressive disorder s
ketamine which is marketed under the
brand name sprovado is a nasal spray
that patients self-administer under a
doctor's supervision ketamine is made up
of a pair of compounds s ketamine and
r-ketamine that are like mirror images
of each other whereas ketamin can no
longer be patented these two component
compounds can be patented which is why
the pharmaceutical company Jansen was
able to turn S ketamine into a
marketable drug today there are several
different types of businesses that
specialize in ketamine therapy the most
common or smaller practices run by
doctors or therapists for patients who
would prefer to avoid traveling to a
clinic or office there are virtual
ketamine clinics like mind bloom or New
Life these startups allow ketamine to be
prescribed and sent to patients via
Telehealth lastly there's larger clinics
like field trip health or Ember health
one of the newest larger clinics is
nushama which opened its Flagship
location on Manhattan's Park Avenue in
October 2021 when people walk in from
the chaos of the streets of New York we
want people to have their anxiety drop
we also want them to feel extremely safe
but not in the context of feeling like a
cold hospital-like environment ushama
calls itself a psychedelic Wellness
Center not a clinic and it refers to its
clients as members not patients all
perspective new shama members receive a
medical and psychiatric evaluation from
anushama doctor or nurse to determine if
ketamine treatment is right for them
ushama says it turns away about 10
percent of potential patients if they
have a substance abuse problem untreated
psychiatric conditions or certain
medical conditions like high blood
pressure and heart disease
okay once approved a typical treatment
for an individual runs about forty five
hundred dollars that includes six
on-site high-dose sessions which are
administered by board certified
anesthesiologists over three to six
weeks we've reached profitability in
less than a year's time which is pretty
unheard of for businesses uh especially
startups currently nushama has four
locations in New York City the company
said it plans to scale up over the next
five years and open an additional 35
clinics across the Northeast
why the Northeast roughly 60 million
people in the Northeast alone so it's a
wonderful opportunity and there's a high
rates of depression anxiety and other
mood disorders here and it isn't just
nushama field trip said it plans to open
75 clinics across the country by 2024. I
wouldn't call it a gold rush but I would
call it a great opportunity billionaire
entrepreneur Adam Weitzman is one of new
shama's earliest investors Weitzman is
the owner of Upstate Shredding the East
Coast's largest privately owned scrap
metal processor and recycler nushama is
his first investment in the Psychedelic
space I think it's a really profitable
business I think it's a strong cash flow
business and I think it's something that
they can scale you know pretty easy
revenue from U.S ketamine treatments has
grown from 8.3 million dollars in 2017
to 185 million dollars in 2022. in 2020
an estimated 14.8 million U.S adults had
at least one major depressive episode
with severe impairment in the past year
and covid-19 made things even worse the
global prevalence of anxiety and
depression increased by 25 percent in
the first year of the pandemic there's a
tremendous demand for ketamine-assisted
Psychotherapy I'm bombarded with
recommendations wishes for referrals for
treatment it's hard to keep up Dr Gita
vaid is a psychotherapist who runs her
own ketamine-assisted therapy practice
and teaches other therapists how to do
the same insurance companies typically
do not cover ketamine-assisted
Psychotherapy because there haven't been
enough studies comparing it as a
treatment for major depression or
treatment resistant depression although
there is substantial evidence the
ketamine has powerful antidepressant
effects in order to be approved by the
FDA the drug we need to get through
years of tests that would likely cost
billions of dollars
so this really limits access to the
patients for this treatment so it's a
very small population that gets access
to ketamine therapy today
it's important to note that ascetamine
is covered by Insurance since it was
approved by the FDA for treating
depression to reduce costs some clinics
are developing new treatment options
ushama offers group therapy for twenty
eight hundred dollars or just about half
the price for its individual treatment
ushama also has a 35 percent Frontline
workers discount hopefully at some point
insurance will play a part in helping
people pay for the treatment but I also
think there's ways of us to make the
experience less expensive and less
costly by you know these are expensive
addresses we don't have to have the
rents like this at every location we can
go to areas that the rents are less
despite being bullish about the growth
of ketamine treatment none of the
founders investors or clinicians we
spoke with expected ketamine therapy to
take a significant bite out of the
traditional antidepressant Market at
least anytime soon we're Believers that
ssris or antidepressants and
benzodiazepines or or anti-anxiety
medications they do have a role they
just don't work for everyone
so our position at nushama is we're
offering an alternative to that
[Music]